In 2011, I wanted to cover
the uprising in Libya.
So, like so many journalists
we snuck in through Egypt.
We knew that one of the
great risks for us journalists
was getting caught
by Qaddafi's forces.
So, on March 15th 2011,
I was working with
Tyler Hicks, Anthony Shadid
and Steve Farrell
and we were covering the
frontline in Ajdabiya.
We knew that the city
was going to fall
all the signs were there,
civilians were fleeing.
The mortar-rounds were walking
towards our position.
That's a sign that they are
zooming in on a position.
We wanted to stay as long
as we possibly could
to get the freshest reporting.
Our driver started
getting calls saying
Qaddafi's troops
were in the city
and that we had to leave,
and we ignored him.
That's the first mistake,
you never ignore your driver.
We stayed, we kept photographing
and working on the frontline
and by the time we
decided to flee
we drove directly into one
of Qaddafi's checkpoints.
This is the exact position
that we were taken hostage.
If you look at
Bryan Denton's name
he's a photographer for
the New York Times
that's where our
car was stopped.
You have to make a decision
when you approach a
hostile checkpoint.
"Do you stop and announce
yourself as journalists
and hope that they
don't kill you.
Or do you try and drive
through the checkpoint
and hope that they
don't open fire."
We are all yelling
something different
"Drive, go, stop."
Our driver panicked,
he stopped the car
and jumped out,
he said we're journalists.
At that point Qaddafi's troops
ripped us out of the car.
The rebels that we were with
started opening fire
on that checkpoint
and we were caught in
a wall of bullets.
There were bullets everywhere.
I did not get out of
the car at that point.
All the men had jumped out
and had been pulled out.
I was still sitting behind
where the driver had been
sitting on the left-hand side.
I put my head in
my lap and started
sort of prayed that it would
all go away. And it did not.
And so, I felt the
bullets everywhere
and I said, "Okay, I have
to get out of the car."
because a car is not armored,
it does not protect you.
I crawled across the
backseat, jumped out
and one of Qaddafi's troops
was immediately on me
pulling my cameras, of course
I'm pulling back instinctively
which is not very smart,
and so he's pulling back
and we're in the
middle of the road
and I feel bullets everywhere.
So, I suddenly thought, "Okay,
I have to make a run for it."
So, each one of us tried to get
behind this cement building.
When we got behind the building
we were told to lie
face down in the dirt.
Each one of us had a
gun put to our heads.
They were about to execute us,
and the commander came over
and said, "You can't kill them,
they're American."
And we don't know
why he said that
but Anthony later
translated that for us.
In that moment they took
my shoes off my feet
tied me up with my shoe laces
my wrists and my ankles
together and carried me away.
They put me and Steve in one
vehicle on the frontline
and Tyler and Anthony in another
and they kept us there for hours
while sniper-fire, bullets
and bombs rained around us.
We were tied up,
we couldn't go anywhere.
At that point as the
fighting got closer
they decided they
wanted us to live.
The entire time we were
punched in the face.
The men were smashed in the
back of the head with gun-butts
and I was groped.
That went on for the
first three days.
We were eventually put in prison
we spent a night in prison
which actually was
the first time
we were allowed to speak
to each other openly
because before we
were blindfolded
so we were scared to
speak to one another.
Then we were flown to Tripoli
and we were held
there for three days
and eventually we were released.
This is our release as we were
brought to the Turkish embassy.
The Turkish government
was acting as a proxy
for the American
government because
the Americans had
pulled out of Tripoli
And this is our car.
Two weeks later
Bryan Denton went back
to see if they can
find our driver.
Our driver was never seen again.
We don't know if he was
killed in that moment
when he jumped out of the
car, or if he was executed
or if he was put in prison.
But the New York Times
sent a team back
to try and look for him
and they found our car
on the side of the road
and they found my shoe.